you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is nearly here and I'm sure all of you
watching have a big long list of what
games you want to see at this year's e3
we are going to be covering the hottest
games and all of the conference's so
make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss anything
until that fateful day though let's
speculate as to what surprises but as de
may have at their conference this year
[Music]
quake champions has spent some time in
the hands of players with his recent run
of beaters so it makes sense that we
will finally see the final fully fleshed
out first-person shooter on stage this
year I spent some time with quake
champions during the beta and while I
had a lot of fun firing quad damaged
rockets and giving folk with rail guns
I'm interested to see how a very
old-school multiplayer shooter does in
the current gaming space hopefully
they'll show off some new weapons new
maps new characters and if I had to
guess some big support for the eSport
scene it looks like two new games will
be getting announced this year as well
and thanks to various leaks and teasers
we have a pretty good idea of what those
games may be bears of course the next
Wolfenstein game and the evil within -
during their showcase last year Bethesda
started proceedings with this old-school
style ms-dos command line screen on said
screen they list older Wolfenstein games
along with their release dates
Wolfenstein 3d Wolfenstein new order all
of blood followed by the new Colossus
with an unspecified release date when
asked about the e3 tease in an interview
with to let sticks Brian bloom the voice
actor for PJ blaskowitz said I'll be
safe with this answer if you look at
Bethesda XIII 2016 lineup there was a
title hinted at in a very cool way it
sparked a bit of wildfire that's subtle
very simple dose language going through
your titles perhaps we're working on
that as we speak so it seems like a
pretty safe bet that new Colossus could
be the next badass adventure 4bj
audio burn dr. Blasco heads
shoot Stevan stranglin Ozzy son
now when it comes to the evil within -
earlier this year an eagle-eyed neogaf
user spotted a job description for a
translator and a QA position opening at
tango works the roles to be connected to
psycho break to psycho break being the
japanese name for the evil within
tango works have also said that they
wanted the evil within to be a franchise
not just a single game so the chance to
see more of synergy Mikami's terrifying
machinations seemed pretty high some of
this can be supported by an image that
Pete Hines tweeted on the 28th of April
bear III style theme park of Bethesda
land shows - under construction
attractions and also hints at what else
we could see from them at e3 with quake
and Wolfenstein in mind we may get to
see more of the old-school shooter
reborn this time in the shape of doom a
year after release doom has been
supported with a number of multiplayer
DLCs but many is still waiting to see
more of doom guys story after that
cliffhanger ending at the end of the
single-player campaign now there's a
chance that Bethesda's conference might
be quite DLC heavy now we've got doom in
mind it may be a little early for them
to be talking about prey DLC but it
seems like a perfect time to talk but
returning to Karnak err
this honour to opened up the world past
the confines of dunwall by I'm unsure
whether a dishonor to DLC will go beyond
the seas of Konica or explore the
characters similar to the knife of
dunwall dlc i've excited to play through
some of the moments between the two
games see Emily's training or perhaps
explore the shady past of Megan Foster
or even her shady of future at the end
of dishonored - with the incredible
amount of replayability and with the
support Dishonored two's free updates it
seems like the time is right to dig out
our folding swords and set sail back to
the jewel of the south at the edge of
the world for everyone still exploring
the world of the Elder Scrolls you may
get some more content for Elder Scrolls
online Elder Scrolls online morrowind
releases on June the 6th the week before
e3 so but there's Damai be keen to share
with their players what's next for their
MMO there's still tons of Tamriel to
explore which means plenty more
potential expansions and worlds for
players to reverse an adventure through
new lands new items perhaps even new
classes with quite a healthy player base
and the support of a huge IP and more
law than you can shake a Khajiit stale
app things could be good for Elder
Scrolls online for a long while to come
and speaking of Elder Scrolls you can
call me optimistic all you like but I'm
hopeful we will get some hints towards
the next full single-player Elder
Scrolls adventure there was a four year
gap between Morrowind and Oblivion
followed by a five-year gap between
oblivion and Skyrim and has been nearly
six years since skyrim graced our pcs
and consoles so the timing seems right
with Skyrim coming to the switch and the
special edition being released last year
the environment seems right for the next
Elder Scrolls adventure thousands of
people still play this incredible series
over a number of different systems and
thousands more want to explore those
untouched areas of Tamriel now will we
get to see gameplay or a release date I
doubt it but a nice little tease I'm
hoping so and while we're talking about
our hopes and dreams if we could get
some information on whether or not
obsidian are working on the next Fallout
game I think that would make a lot of
vault dwellers very happy here's hoping
so while Bethesda are keeping their
secrets locked up for e3 this year this
is our list of what we're hopeful for
and what we may see the third of
surprises numerous times in the past
with our announcements and I'm sure
they've got something up their sleeve if
there are any Bethesda titles you're
hopeful for make sure you leave them in
the comment section below and if you
want to keep up to date with everything
III 2017 you can subscribe to our
YouTube channel and download the games
one now app for your eyes to keep you in
the know when you're on the go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah see wha my home the sacred oasis
be my eyes salut
this temple resembles a fortress what
has happened
[Music]
there you are Matt Nauman the next
masked one on my list
now it is my turn to tip the balance of
Anubis
you
better be careful here
uh fine bow
good
they will surely discreet dangerous good
pass for now
guide me send me tuna muna
[Music]
you will die do not wanna die
see what is mine
trying to be
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you
what would you do
if the world you knew
who's gone all the comforts
the simple pleasures he took for granted
how would you protect yourself and the
ones you love when the protectors can't
even save themselves
the Army's pulling out come on
last truck get in
how will you decide who belongs
how will you choose a place to call home
how will you build it
[Music]
work together to defend it
from the terror
just outside the words
and you get hungry cold what risks will
you take what mistakes
will you make and the only family you've
got is about to tear itself apart will
you end a life wait or save it please
this is our only one we need everybody
we've got
get into deep realize no one gets a
second chance
[Music]
how will you find the strength to carry
on
[Music]
in this world of the living and the dead
how will you survive
you
hi I'm John Warner games record for
anthem here is the world premiere of
anthems gameplay
freelancer frag slang listen in trouble
big trouble what did you do mistake I
hired some people they weren't
freelancers I know they said they could
handle it and the price was right
I thought maybe unbelievable you're
right
it was stupid I'm sorry but they're
still out there somewhere
if you could just bring them back
anything you need
in the world of anthem you and your
friends are freelancers the heroes who
leave the safety of the walls of poor
Tarsus to explore the unknown and
protect humanity
let's join two players as they head out
on an expedition you ready to go
just grab us some supplies just already
what are you gonna use today other
side's go with the Colossus
I'm gonna use my ranger try out some new
upgrades
every player will own an array of
exosuits we call javelins these suits
give players superhuman capabilities and
are heavily customizable so they look
and play how you want good nice you got
a mortar equipped yeah I got on the
weekend you lead the way
[Music]
this is a vast open world you explore
with your friends each javelin exosuit
has its own unique play style the Ranger
is balanced in all purpose while the
Colossus is a tanking powerhouse let's
see what's up here
the world of anthem is hostile and
threats can come from any direction
dynamic world was unexpected this around
every corner yeah he seems like a
problem for another day
Squire the heavy although low you flank
have you been in there yet heaven I wish
to do that later with Kim you could use
the XP
hello expression
I think we got smacked you man
we're under attack anyone in the area
we're under attack think that's part of
prac situation
you can equip your javelin exosuit with
gear that brings devastating power to
combat there are a lot of scars down
there all the scars have a heavy top use
that mortar there's a bunch more coming
in okay I'll get this round
oh good Jerry's rap oh nice large-scale
world events like shaper storms are
dynamic and pull you off the beaten path
with the promise of new stories to
discover Oh shiver storm incoming okay
actually let's get some more people hold
on a second hey guys what's up hey
what's happening
right behind you
Oh
this storm is getting crazy
so are we supposed to do fly into it
see on the upside
our story is out there
you prod to you Millie ate me he left
your mark on me buddy thing work you
burn my nine dog I'll kill you until
this moment you have not known suffering
all right another your mouth bruise so
now I'm gonna kill you for all these
orcs to say oh I said you were an
optimist know what that is might it's
about sizing up a situation that's
bloody impossible and saying here odd
I'll have a go I'm exactly the same way
I like him in shadow of Mordor we
introduced a way to create unique
personal stories for every player and in
shadow of war we're expanding the
Nemesis system to new features we're
really excited about our forging an army
and followers and nemesis fortresses
here we use the ring of power and
recruit this Olaf Brewster chopper to
expand our army then we're going to
assault a fortress controlled by one of
sour rods over love
racheal guy to skewer may that little
swords good for a tickle maybe were you
gonna need more than that chance I may
down noise one Ranger
this [ __ ] happened to be
Bry Lord our Lord same thing really
it results me ripping spines out which I
like to do anyway so either ways a win a
fine addition to our man nice birds from
your owner
I will be your shadow no one gets to you
without my say-so
don't worry about my enemies they will
all follow eventually you want to apply
your flag in Mordor you'll need to do a
deep there's a fortress near boy
I said ruled by a two-headed troll
pretty son man mmm
deadly smart which Marcus he'd have to
be given the two heads you takin down
you sent a message to Sauron anger
yourself some nice new digs as part of
the bargain we're not going to do this
alone gather your troops will do up just
make sure you let me poppies haze of
words yeah
[Music]
so we already have a few loyal followers
in our army and recruiting booth means
we're ready to assault the fortress and
overthrow the overlord we're enormous ly
expanding the open-world of Mordor to
new regions like Sarah Gaston Tirith
angle mortars a massive living breathing
world filled with orc society tribes and
wildlife as well as stories and secrets
you gravely in to any other Oracle have
died but I survived more than that I
thrived my brothers put me back together
stronger than ever but they didn't make
me into what I am you Jade's you created
the machine machine he's trying to
across board or seeking vengeance he's
one of the seven-year-old priority
we will grind you to pilot school
you disorder the steel
instead of killing the machine will
dominate his manner we can take
advantage of his abilities during the
fortress assaults you to do before we
charge headfirst into battle we should
plan our attack and select our followers
[Applause]
my black speech is a little rusty
exelon icing would
she's a pain in the ass back to hazard a
case he sayd we're all gonna die
horribly yeah mark on a black well I
will handle the Overlord you focus on
the defenders to find focus
[Applause]
there are unlimited ways to forge your
story in conquer Mordor in shadow of war
and we can't wait to show you more this
week at e3 thank you very much
[ __ ] they killed the power
around the world we're gonna light it
back up because this is far from over
in fact it's only just begun that's why
we brought in you you got the tower now
you need a you throw grenade
tomorrow you'll be throwing cars forget
dropping bombs you drop it now it's time
to get to work
time to step up
determination
some people never have trouble the fight
they don't know what the struggling
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the joy of a new voyage far across the
sea of thieves just you the wide open
world at Obama's not just you she's here
too oh and the skies here but the point
is this is a shared world right for
exploring and reading with your fine
pirate crew look a scurrying around
making themselves useful that's what we
like to see the world of sea of thieves
seeds with possibilities with adventure
skulking above and below the waves all
you have to do is jump in and up there
she goes
[Music]
few things tend to pirate like the siren
song of a lootable shipwreck careful
though there could be anything down
there literally there could be anything
we haven't finished designing it yet
joking that was a joke ah sunken
treasure it's like a pirate performance
points
every players decisions and discoveries
will be different but however you plan
on seeking your fortune it pays to be
prepared for gigantic lumps of iron
these are surprisingly portable amazing
workmanship anyway bear get them back on
board while the coast is clear
there's really no sense in pushing your
luck down here and that is not a beast
you want to pick a fight with yes it's
possible to take on these two theatres
of the deep you're not much used to your
crew betting in two
[Music]
sometimes a tactical key is perfectly
acceptable in the spirit of that
legendary pirate captain pathetic team
[Music]
thankfully for every tense standoff
there's a moment of celebration who are
shared wonder but for now store your
hard-earned loot and enjoy the voyage on
Devil's read beneath the sands the gold
lies hidden from thieving hands that's
typical oh look here we are at Devil's
Ridge nice transition by the way
and so you shift from the heart of the
sea to the island shore where you'll
explore jungles and coves cliff tops and
caverns every region has it's very own
landmarks and over time you'll uncover
hidden shortcuts abandoned stashes and
Vestas they'll steal your grog soak
breath away and yes sometimes you'll
encounter people who for whatever reason
would like to blow you into little
pieces that's hiring for you keep that
pestle cranked because you'll also face
the roaming remains of those Raiders who
came before you cut short in pursuit of
their own legends
and afterlife of waiting and trouble
McLean tell all your bets fall off its
what it would have wanted now make sure
your crewmates all depart to play yep
that works and look they brought the
riddle map seek the cursed borscht rain
where there is no sky it lies and wheat
for a length held high right well that's
gotta be around here somewhere but if
you've got bad feeling you can always
leave someone on board to brace the ship
for a speedy galley decisions decisions
ah looks like they've snuffed out that
place where there's no sky time to pull
your resources as you plunge into the
unknown
it would be easy to come a cropper in
these claustrophobic caves you don't
want to wander off track unless of
course you're streaming and you got
loads of people in the chat telling you
what to do anyway
is probably not just kids
of course the premier plunder isn't just
lying around to be clean by any old
drunken bum block you'll need to watch
out for likely locations following your
map clues and your instincts to make a
light work of each new mystery
late work well Blanton joke there you're
welcome
anyway step 11 paces Northwest through
the gloom beg my chest from its tomb and
with that we're one step closer to
payday then again some of the loot in
these parts has lain undisturbed for a
long long time that has to be the spot
you can practically taste the treasure
good call on the double duty shovel work
to that store mate says was nothing in
your heels ah very nice
of course the trouble with treasure as a
rule is that the owners really like to
hang on tests if you've got your hands
full
it's up to your crew to watch your back
and while they're doing that it's
playing for another strategic withdrawal
with the loot
nope not that way that's it easy no
don't stop keep going almost there watch
that next step is it easy
that's a rescue
[Music]
then we can regularly beat the odds and
get chest back to your ship you'll be
able to turn a tidy profit by trading
the men and opals that's just their tiny
matter of making it through this storm
in one piece
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all pirate life is here on the sea of
thieves and you can let viewers however
you want so rally your crew
Saints Aylmer wretches and infamy become
a pirate of legend
just try not to be this one
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to
GameSpot's III stage in approximately 30
minutes Bethesda is going to take their
own stage to start their press
conference at 9 p.m. Pacific
late night press conference but right
now we figured we get together hang out
talk about our predictions our hopes for
that press conference I'm your host Mike
McCarty I'm here Justin hey Walt howdy
howdy
Jess McDonald hello and Dave do it I
know we know a few things about the
conference that we're gonna see we
there's been a few leaks throughout this
week the leak ends but it's you free
like it wouldn't be free without thanks
very big key three very substantial
number of them and we're Bethesda games
but we can get to that I want to start
off the ones that we know will probably
see Dave do it you played a fair amount
of quite champions no but yeah and you
play a lot of shooters you play a lot of
overwatch I know that you've been
playing like battlegrounds and whatnot
but quite champions we'll probably see
more of tonight at the press conference
so far what are your impressions of the
game like obviously it's they've
Bethesda's done really good with these
reboots of old school shooters
Wolfenstein the new order being one or
the new Colossus which we can get into
and then doom of course last year which
is fantastic in my opinion but quake
champions a lot of people are hesitant
to say whether it's you know it pays
good homage to the older games but in
your opinion how has it been so far it's
it's funny you mentioned doom because
the multiplayer for doom very much felt
like it was an experiment towards
towards quake there's a there's a lot of
parallels between the two quake is more
fluid it's more refined but there's
loads of it that really just rubs me the
wrong way it's free-to-play and you can
do things like rent new here champions
which is fine but there are small
differences between each champion and it
can be kind of frustrating when you're
sinking all those hours in you want to
play a certain way and it's just kind of
well the models are really different but
it seems like in some ways this would be
their answer to overwatch and it hasn't
capture people's attention in the same
way quite I mean it's not out yet but
now the champions are nearly is
different as the heroes in overwatch
there's only minor things but the core
gameplay it plays like you expect a
quake to it is it really is the the tie
quick quake that a lot of people knew
and loved but it's it's it's the very
surface level stuff that's that's
frustrating but from my I played you can
play it completely free to play without
being held back in any way which is in
the in like today's gaming market is
such a plus yeah so like mechanically in
terms of how it feels feel like quake
quake to the games you remember yeah
absolutely they've they've done a really
good job it's it's super fluid and super
responsive I played on PC I can't read
comment how to play anywhere else but
from I played it just it felt like when
I used to do up like my Windows XP
machine play button play quake
yeah it looks Priya just did you play
the older quake games and all you get
the chance there they don't really think
oh I pretty much missed quake but you
know you have to respect the fact that
they're bringing back the household name
and you know I like what they're doing
of that I like what they've done with
doom and hopefully we can see them not
let down the name but yeah I think it's
going to attract people just because
it's quake at the end of the day so you
know hopefully the mechanics stuck up
yeah obviously the shooter to compare
things to or at least one of them is
overwatch and I think when people saw
the champions they assumed that maybe
they're going for this like hero shooter
kind of thing to compete with that but
you know you look at the actual gameplay
and help sorry lawbreakers doesn't have
the same visibility as overwatch but
gameplay wise I think this is actually
more similar to that just an easier type
of games would you prefer something that
with overwatch like I know you're a
mercy main if I'm not mistaken right
nice my mercy that's not a negative so I
don't - I'm just saying like it
I wouldn't say mercy mains or would love
quake off the bat I would say maybe like
if you're a McCree fan or someone or I
don't know like a Widowmaker I always
love Team Fortress 2 like I love games
where you're playing in a group and you
get to to take a role and I love being a
support class and quite to me has always
been one of those competitive games like
I love counter-strike and I loved
playing that with my friends and like
that's that kind of that kind
a competitive aspect of it and quake has
always meant that to me it's very
fast-paced and it means unforgivingly
aggressive and how good you have to be
and I'm not I'm not the best super
player I have a mercy main partially
because my aim is so bad you can hold a
button and go to the next play this is
really good oh but looks like I'm
intrigued by quake from that nostalgia
point of view like I remember growing up
and like quake to me like playing that
like that was just a high-end PC game
like that's something that was stressing
your PC to its limits and nostalgia why
is it for me it doesn't quite hold up as
much as the experience of something like
overwatch which has brought me in in a
new way I don't know if I want to go
back to quick Dave from the time you
spend with this game so far what do you
think they'll show tonight that we
haven't seen so far my assumption is
that they might show up like new
champions on your Maps but I'm guessing
they're gonna try and push for some like
heavy eSports
like that's that's something that every
den publisher wants to push now doesn't
really have a foothold in that but at
the same time they've got this giant IP
that's got a lot of a lot of a lot of
legs too it's got a lot of history to it
and the original quakes did have that
that eSports prestige and it gave birth
to a lot of other games I think they're
gonna want to start like quake
tournaments right
I do wanna move over to Elder Scrolls is
we're likely to see potentially other
sports nice but unfortunately not the
one you want yeah but the one you're
getting yes well a few so I will start
with Elder Scrolls online just released
morrowind last week yeah and people went
playing that um don't you guys play up
scrolls online I know you've dabbled in
it right Josh I played it when it came
out yeah
Laurel wind like I think was a really
good way to reinvigorate the the
franchise like it isn't a really
interesting take on it and bringing
people back in but at the same time it's
especially for people and our line of
work getting sucked into an MMO is
already a really hard thing to do it's a
scary prospect Roland didn't quite have
enough to keep me going yeah um do you
think we'll see anything more from that
tonight like Dave you and I were talking
about like you know like our wildest
dream would be Elder Scrolls 6 right
yeah and you know we got really geeky
about it and the naming conventions you
know every other game is actually made
by the location it's set in so
Skyrim and there's a geography and
Morrowind but then there's like arena
and oblivion so the next one ostensibly
whenever it gets announced would not be
called like elsewhere Black Marsh these
locations that exist in Tamriel but you
were saying you'd think that this house
will be more likely to use one of those
locations as maybe a feature expansion
in alta girls online I think that might
be something we see tonight a week after
morrowind releases I'm not sure if we're
gonna see any specifics but because
Marvin just came out and it's got that
reinvigoration I think now would be a
really smart time to show the future of
Elder Scrolls online a lot of fans have
jumped back into it there's a lot of
longtime fans they're all going to want
to know what the one-year plan is the
two-year plan is the five-year plan is
because an MMO it's when you play an MMO
you wanna you want it to be there for a
long time like world of warcraft is
still huge
you want that character that you've
build that story you've built that
experience you've built to go on for a
long time so I think that's every Elder
Scrolls online fan wants to know what's
gonna happen in the next months years I
think that's why they gonna show off
it's an interesting time for Bethesda as
well because having just brought out
morrowind I was reading up on it and you
can actually just start a new character
in the morrowind expansion so for
character for people who had kind of
armed and on about it I played it for a
few hours hoping it was going to be the
single-player Elvis Cole's game that I
wanted it to me and I'm not a huge fan
of MMOs and it kind of brought me down
because of that but the fact that you're
going to be able to play in Morrowind
and we didn't get that and morrowind
remaster that i think some of us had our
fingers crossed for uh it is a chance to
react Splore that world and because it's
been so many years since we've had
Skyrim I mean I'm certainly tempted as
an Elder Scrolls fan just to try the MMO
thing again just so I can explore
morrowind and there is a lot of people
who say it does work as a single-player
experience so it'll be interesting to
see if it can pull people in I think
it's going to be all about the Elder
Scrolls online marketing push just
trying to get people into that game this
is the perfect time for it to go deeper
into the Elder Scrolls rabbit-hole elder
scrolls legends trading card game just I
know you play a lot of hearthstone in
your time obviously we have Gwent now
which a bunch of people on staff have
been playing which of course arose out
of The Witcher 3 as
mini-game announced a full game but
Ellis girl is taking its turn at the
deck building yeah I played a lot of
magic back in the day and I love this
turn towards online card based games
because I don't feel like even though
I'm sometimes spending a ridiculous
amount of money I don't feel like I'm
spending quite as much I don't have
boxes of embarrassing cards that I have
to hide in a closet or what they call a
whale yeah yeah spending too much money
on these the turn that they're doing
with Elder Scrolls legends like once it
gets on phone like that's when it's
going to blow up but I think what's
different about it is is this focus on
kind of a single-player experience which
you're missing and hearthstone which are
missing in Gwent like and I'm really
intrigued by how that's going to pull in
Elder Scrolls fans because that's what
you want in $1.00 well not only that
actually has a really somewhat
interesting quest system because like
again much like online it's trying to
pull in the single a PG fans and as you
play along I played a few hours of this
one so far you it's got a story mode
basically so as you go along you know
you're facing against wolves the wolves
come in the form of cards you're facing
against you know brigands and they come
as cards as well um I I personally think
it's a fairly solid game it's really
hard for it to find a market to compete
in right now against games like
hearthstone but it's I think still got
that appeal it's got that Elder Scrolls
name so I reckon as you say when it
comes to phones when it comes to mobile
it might actually find some fans is it
just on PC right now yeah it's on
tablets as well it's coming it's like
it's very slowly making that transition
so you can't lead on tablet devices I
think they've got a good opportunity to
kind of complement each other now yeah
like if they made some compatibility
between Elder Scrolls legends and Elder
Scrolls online like if you could play in
game for example play Elder Scrolls
legends on your phone to earn rewards in
online that would get both player bases
but first I had the marketing position
open I think you might want to go talk
to Mara Syndication uh-uh that Blizzard
comparison like heroes of the storm is a
game that I think does really well
because it yes yeah drawing that
overwatch fans if you do the same thing
I would have never played here's the
storm if it wasn't that yeah deep scan
several people on our staff would
go into play like however many matches
required for the new Gangi scanner Thank
You totally work that out before we move
off elder scrolls you think we'll see
Skyrim on switch tonight yes yeah no I
mean even though they they have
completely not confirmed it yeah it's on
and there's a Nintendo page with the
Elder Scrolls it was what I call a mess
yeah I guys play on the plane switch
announcer it's the weirdest thing we're
besides I was like yeah we have it but
it's not confirmed its yeah it's a
hundred percent confirmed and I think
that's what they're gonna like it's not
gonna be part of Nintendo's conference
they have thirty minutes and I think the
the Bethesda one is also going to be
pretty short but they're definitely
going to take time out and show the game
on switch yes though I supp rooting for
Skyrim yeah and then as far as we're
talking about things that Todd Howard
would be likely to announce and tie
might fall out for VR for a long time oh
yeah you think tonight's the night we
finally there's a lot of happen yeah I
mean I've talked to him a few times over
the last year so about like fallout 4
stuff and Skyrim on switch and just you
know like where open world games are
going in general and he always talks
about it and of course I'm I'm sure he
feels obligated to but this is one of
those things that actually seems gets me
excited for VR I played through
resonable seven and B are but fallout 4
the idea of that open like massive open
world in VR seems like something I could
really get lost in and I'm still
skeptical about how you know immersive
it's gonna be if like you know
everything VR seems like toned down to
support the panel it does I mean that's
the dream isn't it like being able to
play like a Bethesda RPG I think I mean
at least for me when I first heard about
VR I was like that's what I want oh my
gosh I want to be in that world I want
to be in you know elder scrolls I want
to be in fallout but I don't know how
practical it's gonna be I was the
opposite I work I I'm one of many that
who don't really enjoy the feel of VR
get kind of motion says yeah and I know
the controls have fallout for a very
different you have like that the
teleport thing to stop you from feeling
that but I also spend I will immersed
like eight hours into an RPG I don't
want to be wearing that thing very hours
because I will probably just turn inside
out from it I don't get sick but
especially this last year and having a
lot more VR experiences come out playing
them for multiple hours at a time it
doesn't make me sick it's just tiring
it's yeah
during its mentally tiring it's
physically not as much fun and that
doesn't work for me for a fallout game
like this something that I'm going to
spend eight to ten hours at a time
playing I feel like they need to find a
middle ground because I mean well what
we saw next year was you know
teleporting around the gas station and
they did say it's not just going to be
teleportation that's not going to be the
only method of moving around you are
going to be able to they haven't said
specifically but there'll be other ways
of moving around the landscape but yeah
at the same time I agree you couldn't
have a full like RPG fallout 4
experience so I I would really like to
see them hit an agreeable middle ground
like maybe some kind of side quest where
you still feel like you're adventuring
maybe it's a shorter kind of time limit
or just like little packaged units that
you can play at a time and still wonder
around or have the choice I think that
could be cool yeah I do want to move on
to a couple bigger things that we think
as we'll announce seeker as far as
standalone games we are talking about
Wolfenstein - the new Colossus which was
a rumor for a while because of last
year's e3 but that's to start off their
press conference by talking about or
there was that das intro right and it
showed doom and then something called
the new colossal it was all the
Wolfenstein games with its bit that
release date right and then new Colossus
exactly pretty brazen way to just write
everything away no one noticed at the
time but of course like the more you
mind it the more you see that omi people
sign to the new Colossus then the other
day yesterday I think Amazon Germany
something pops up called Stein - the new
Colossus and now if you know your poetry
you know that that is the poem that's
written on the base of Statue of Liberty
it's also the poem BJ blaskowitz is
reciting at the end of Nevada yeah Brian
bloom the voice actor who's also the
protagonist in called the infinite
warfare and he's a writer on infinite
warfare
he had tweeted saying like something
about BJ blaskowitz coming back so we're
pretty sure based on all that in from
information that will see Wolfenstein 2
tonight I absolutely loved a new order
is one of my favorite game - 2014 I
don't know Dave you seem to know your
Wolfenstein pretty well are you pretty
excited for this I am incredibly excited
for this like
Bethesda are doing such credit to the
old-school shooter and
but Wolfenstein games the new order the
old world fantastic I am really excited
to see whether going next to this
franchise and I was noting out with you
before talking some theories again
there's that the poem thing it's
connected to the Statue of Liberty so I
think they're gonna think they're going
to everybody come alive and fight you
well I think that's what are we talking
about so they did they did the whole
thing with a deliberate liberated Europe
from from deaths head so it makes sense
they're going to go to America now and
with the whole the new Colossus poem it
makes sense they're going to go to New
York and it's not out of the realms
possibly maybe this is meters being a
stupid fanboy but I'm imagining they
actually just turn the Statue of Liberty
into a mech suite you wouldn't play that
I'll be all about it to pilot at the end
like I just want to stand up in the
Statue of Liberty's crown and the tops
either responsibly like the torch
Wolfenstein is insane like it wouldn't
like it's got the occult in it why why
not be populated baby pretty bombastic
oh yeah do a wheel that's alright about
it yes look at people yeah oh my gosh oh
yeah except machine guns starts just
gonna okay well what this so great about
Wolfenstein right and then uh Bethesda
we're talking about all machine games
the next project back before they
announced it and I won't do any Swiss
but Pete Hines is like oh what they
working on right now is like effing
bananas yeah what if they bring what do
they bridge the gap between Wolfenstein
and doom and the new Colossus is the
thing that brings these universes
together I mean that is effing bananas
so I'm not sure if it'll get bananas
bpj though because at the end of the
game it's implied that BJ dies or be at
off-screen you hear the helicopter come
in or you hear the sound effect of a
helicopter yeah after the credits right
looks back from hell that's from doom
lifts if it's not BJ I'm hoping that its
might in my mind's eye over this image
of BJ's kid 4 cos M he hooked up with
the the Polish resistance lady Anja I
think it was yeah i imagining BJ's kid
is his is super badass door it's set in
the 80s she got a biker jacket on a
big mad big big hair with a bandana and
she's just going through New York
kicking that yeah I'll play that yeah to
saw travels in a pompadour it's all you
need how yeah um peggeleh yeah deep so
you think like it'll just continue the
story son because the first one was won
1960 it was it was sixties yeah but um I
don't think they would have chosen like
Wolfenstein - yeah it was like gonna be
a prequel or something yeah yeah that's
true
so I think I think the BJS alive and he
was rescued or it's his kid so would it
still be like World War 2 era Nazi
weaponry or would it be like like even
more developed obviously like no it's
not historical they weren't giant wolf
max but I think it'd be really
interesting to see and that that I know
of they correct me if I'm wrong but the
first of the previous Wolfenstein it was
it was set in Europe that was where
death's-head compound was purely they
evade it from America yeah I think it'd
be quite interesting to see that the
resistance is now occupying Europe the
American resistance on Europe and they
are retaking America actual yeah
obviously they've spent time rebuilding
Europe and you know consolidating that
and now it's back overseas to actual
America obviously New York's you know
East Coast so yeah that makes sense yeah
I know maybe I'm going like way too far
this way no I'm excited for that and we
excited to see what it like what they
actually choose to do with it did you
play the new order hmm you just play the
old blood thanks passion which is really
good ready get more supernatural focus
it was more like the occult gym and
stuff that they liked to play with super
weird but like obviously that the new
order was cool because you can kind of
choose to go stealth if you wanted to
although I mean I love stealth games and
that's usually the path I choose but
when you could do a wield shotguns
within first 10 minutes of a game I'm
not gonna lie quiet well that's the
great thing in stealth games when you
bugger up stealth you know I reload but
in this you go stuff a bit like iron
doesn't matter okay shotguns
yeah I'll throw an eye for this dude and
then I'll pull out my double assault
rifle yeah yeah yeah the old blood is
well worth playing as well if you
haven't like and I can remember was that
like part of the main story of the first
game or was it like this complete
offshoot I did wasn't explaining that
wasn't that like the actual old blood
yeah the old blood was set before the
new order which it was like the dig
where they dug up the stuff that caused
all the supernatural yeah I think the
the Scottish guy you meet with and you
start the game with was
in the old blood okay so they were
definitely connected but then the new
order didn't really touch on the occult
stuff so it kind of felt standalone in
that so it stands a reasonable we will
definitely see new classes tonight if
that leak is true and not even leak if
that what if that sales page on Amazon
Germany is oh yeah rumors from the last
few months and whatnot um another one
that seems semi likely is the evil
within two from tango GameWorks Michigan
economy of resin evil creation fame evil
within the first one released as well in
2014 under Bethesda and I liked it alive
there's fifteen chapters in it and I
loved the first ten could not stand the
last third of the game so it showed a
lot of potential I think it was at its
best when like Mikami and his team we're
doing the things that they became known
for like in resin well for when you have
this open sandbox village and kind of
you're just trying to survive uh Jess
did you get the chance to play the evil
within the first one yeah I played the
first few hours of it um I'm great with
horror games as anyone who I yeah I mean
I like the tense moments I like the
atmosphere um I think this story sort of
came and went in waves with this one
they're obviously playing with
psychological elements I'm not sure all
of them hit the mark
now but what I'm really interested in is
this was like on the whole you know
fairly critically agreed to be a solid
game even like for its flaws so I do
hope they're making a sequel because I'd
love to see what they can take as
lessons from the game they're already
made and you know because they had a lot
of great elements including the
atmosphere it's absolutely [ __ ] scary so
you know if they can if they can pull
together the things that perhaps they
fell short on like the story uh it would
be a really interesting game to play
yeah I can't like even just watching
this game play I can't stand the main
character uh yes I think it's Sebastian
Castellanos although I think I said that
didn't I was wrong I think you're um no
I said it was Sebastian but I said
Salvatore yeah he's very different
um but yeah just to reiterate the reason
that we think this might show up is
there was a psycho break two job post
recent and psycho break is what this
franchise called in Japan and also I
when they they've been talking a lot
Bethesda and tango gameworks and Mikami
himself are saying they wanted to be a
franchise they don't they didn't just
want to be a one-off thing from the
beginning and I'm curious where they
would go after the first one because the
first one took a toll on the main
character and I wonder if they'll keep
going with him I imagine they would
although only Mikami and his crazy cast
from Resident Evil and how many
different protagonists around yeah I
wonder if they would go with someone
else and start by you know like that
franchise building wise I wonder if they
take a completely new character in this
universe and kind of tie it in lightly
and then maybe the next one comes along
and they're together or it's a
completely new person and then you get
to the evil within six and it's just
everybody there's three campaigns
there's six characters mad I'm just
kidding yeah I'm making fun of his ego
six but Justin are you excited for even
within two if they do announce it
tonight I mean especially after Resident
Evil 7 like I thought I was done with
Resident Evil and having that game come
back in such a big way like it was
exciting
like how frightening how scary and
atmospheric it was yeah and so coming
back I when I first saw that rumor I was
like well I leave with him one wasn't
that great do I really want to go back
to the second one and after playing
Resident Evil actually makes me more
excited about it because like there's
the possibility they can do it better
you put the resources behind it and
especially seeing how Resident Evil
reinvented itself if it wasn't - could
totally do that
ya know it's I mean this would be
something I would show up during Sony if
it happened but a lot of people after or
even before resident sudden release have
been waiting for resin able to remake
and we were talking the other day it
stands to reason that now would be as
best the best time of any for Capcom to
release that just riding the wave of
Resident seven of course they're going
to talk more about the not a hero DLC
with a spoiler but one of the returning
iconic characters of the earlier games
and I feel like now would be the best
like you know strike while the iron's
hot which was able to remake but like
you said it seems like survival horror
has been kind of undergoing this triple
a renaissance lately thanks to like
maybe it was like silent hill's came
along and then that that's can't the
cancellation of that game under Kojima
and Guillermo del Toro people are like
maybe there is a market for these kind
of things even though traditional
survivor survival horror kind of faded
for about like a decade or something
aside from the evil within which is one
of the ones that kept it alive so I'm
pretty excited if we do see
within 2 I would like to and then I do
want to kind of like talk about
collective hopes which might not be as
logical or reasonable Danny what is a
Bethesda congressman illogical oh yeah
do you think we'll see anything like
fallout shelter that they're gonna come
onstage be like oh by the way you can
play this right now like anything new
years I feel like this is the time when
you're gonna release some other new
mobile I don't think it's gonna be like
fallout shelter because that was
surprising in how kind of fresh and
different it was like yeah you remember
e3 and like everybody was playing again
walking around you're like well this
quirky little mobile game and I would
love for them to do that again to take
like some kind of cool idea and make it
into a mobile game that all of us are
going to be playing on the show floor
well do you think they'll just be like
Elder Scrolls Legends is available right
now that's exactly our zones yeah I'd
love to do that yeah that's the love to
do and I'm just wondering like I don't
have a like clarified why they did such
a late conference this year because it
doesn't like work well for people in the
UK that's like what's 6:00 a.m. 5:00
a.m. 5:00 6:00 at night but I'm
wondering yeah if they're saying like as
of midnight this thing is dropping get
your phone out I don't know but uh so
like that's what you're hoping for
something like that kind of thing I
think that'd be a lot of fun yeah I
Elder Scrolls let like I do want to play
a little scrolls edge with my phone but
I feel like maybe that's not the thing
that's gonna happen like I want
something surprising
I love the surprises of e3 and that's
what I want yeah
on a date what about you I mean get
weird if you want my pipe dream is that
you know that obsidian fallout yeah I'm
like New Vegas is my baby it's my
favorite for I've got hundreds and
hundreds of hours in that game and
obsidian just did an incredible job with
it the setting the atmosphere the
gameplay it it just took it seems like
it's going cyclical I remember when
fallout 3 came out there was tons of
criticisms for that game but it was
widely received then obsidian came out
with Fallout New Vegas and it kind of
fixed a lot of what was wrong with
fallout 3 and added like a lot of humor
and character and ambience and
atmosphere to it and fallout 4 kind of
feels like it's the same
so if obsidian bring out their version
like I know we were talking that it
could possibly be New Orleans yeah that
would be like that would be end of show
for me as far as oh yeah it's weird it
all started with a fake like it was
proven to be fake post that obsidian was
working on Fallout New Vegas to
and then but the original rumors came
from the fact that they had mentioned
project Louisiana a few times and then
there was something in Fallout 4 that
made reference to New Orleans a few
times and then yeah New Vegas was two
years after three now as two years after
four it might be the time although they
are working on the crowdfunded um
tyranny pillars of eternity - ah the
first one was the debut play pillars of
eternity
yeah did you like it yeah good game the
great storytellers I mean that's the
reason to be excited for it okay so you
know like they're working on the sequel
but I wonder if they did have like do
you have people that have been working
hard so every fiber of my being hopes
I'd be awesome especially like New
Orleans I mean Mafia 3 went there we had
like even like Point Lookout the DLC for
Fallout 3 was kind of swampy marshy area
that was really cool
I'd be curious to see how you do a
post-apocalyptic new you and Nana gays
yeah radio at gumbo and like fan boats
and boats yeah had a big paddle one's a
stronghold yeah hopefully someone not
telling you to go this outpost every
five minutes
it'd be great no three dog 303 yeah yeah
Jess what about you do you have anything
that you're hoping to see that we
probably won't I just want Elder Scrolls
every damn yet I know it won't come I
know it'll probably be another two years
and also I don't think the first time we
see it's gonna be at e3 call me a
skeptic about leaky III but I just feel
like we're gonna get you know a LinkedIn
listing like a job is gonna be here are
we gonna get like a weird screen like I
feel like we're gonna know it's coming
before it arrives I wish you wouldn't I
would just love for us to have an e3
but that's depressive it's just like and
now Elvis girls 6 in this amazing place
and there's like new scenery but you
know I remember counting down the days
for Skyrim to come out I make childhoods
built around that you know franchise I
absolutely love it so I know what
happened but uh that that would be my
dream
have you found my the remastered Skyrim
no I haven't because I well I played it
on PC I don't need you after that it
wasn't it wasn't like too big of a thing
for me because of mods but yeah I mean I
just love those worlds I love those
stories I know a lot of people have
burnt out on medieval I've just never
get sick of it I love ya like the I
always love the juxtaposition between
fallout the post like post apocalypse
and then the high fantasy of Elder
Scrolls and I always loved kind of
bouncy
back and forth but uh yeah I would say
it's either the Obsidian fallout if that
were to happen or it might just vaguely
vaguely tease something yeah we were
talking like maybe it was in elsewhere
because that'd be such a contrast of the
snow of Skyrim to the deserts of
elsewhere with a cat people the cadmium
people peeling into that love cat so
yeah perfect game right now
I was always an Argonian person yeah
rusty was really made type from black
yeah from a black marsh like my [ __ ]
yeah are they pretty cool and then we
were also wondering whether to backtrack
a little bit to VR and doom you said you
like people have been there been rumored
to be yeah doom VR which maybe we'll see
that too
I mean we was talking before how do you
have a lot of people motion sickness
never settings you could fiddle yeah
with that to like reduce that a game
they already gives you motion sickness
in VR yeah that's just that should come
packaged yeah a bath bag yeah well we
will find out soon enough
maybe there will be a doom VR we are
going live to the Bethesda press
conference in about five seconds but
stay tuned we will be coming back to
discuss what we see after here on the
GameSpot III stage enjoy great your dad
dude what is he to friction plague on
his computer I don't know I don't know
actually he does effects like sparkles
cuts eats sits a computing does stuff
[Music]
I'm a Senior Programmer I'm at ui
program I'm a senior designer my mom's
an artist she worked for yard I am a
quest designer I'm a senior character
artist yeah definitely is a very
familiar environment my dad makes video
games my mom they stay okay I always
wanted to make games I dreamt of this
kind of job when I was a kid I grew up
loving games when he was little this was
actually his dream job it never occurred
to me that it could be a job sometimes I
still feel like that kid me I'm an adult
sometimes I have to pinch myself that
it's real I love what I do
I mean it's video games for a living
that's got to be really cool of course
my dad's games make people feel happy
scared excited badass all kind of
feelings I'm actually working on an RPG
I'm working on a shooter that's a really
cool mobile game eSports first person
third person fantasy dystopian a horror
game it'll scare the [ __ ] out of you and
finally you're studying everywhere our
game is really exciting awesome scary
overwhelming mind-blowing I'm really
proud of my dad my mom worked hard and
now they're ready they made their game
and this is it let's go John time to
show everyone what we've been working
except me I can't play so I'm older
awesome let's get it started
are you ready oh yeah so let's just say
it start the show
start the show shoot Oh
I don't know what your time is welcome
welcome to the lucky three surveys
[Music]
not able to pay
hahaha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone to bethesda land 2017
yes bethesda land a place of adventure
innovation wonderment but above all else
fun
to get things started please welcome
Bethesda's global vice-president of PR
and marketing Pete Hines
[Applause]
thank you very much I can't even imagine
the size of the bar tab that it paid it
for that applause but I thank you for
that good evening and welcome to the
2017 Bethesda III showcase and welcome
to Bethesda Lane we will offer you an
experience at e3 unlike anything else
and a chance to celebrate some of the
world's best video games tonight we'll
be taking you on a virtual tour through
our playground where there's something
for everyone whether it's phone or
tablet PC or your favorite Xbox
Playstation or tendo console or like
many of us all of the above but before
we turn to the latest from Bethesda
let's take a minute to look at the some
of the most recent games that you've
been playing and many of you are still
enjoying like the endless hours of fun
that millions of fans have had playing
Doom ripping tearing and otherwise
eviscerating demons from hell
did you play a badass supernatural
assassin in Dishonored - or fight to
survive aboard an alien festive Space
Station in prey maybe you're one of the
100 million people around the world who
have enjoyed building and overseeing
your own vault in fallout shelter and I
know that many of you are still playing
fallout 4 and Skyrim special edition
probably because for the first time in
our industry both games offer user mods
for console players with more than 300
million mod downloads since we launched
them last year as each of these
extraordinary games show Bethesda works
hard for you giving players the very
best entertainment experience regardless
of your taste platform or playstyle
so what's next let's start by talking
about virtual reality something that
we've been at the forefront of for a
while now we've had teams hard at work
on VR titles to provide the kind of
experiences you've been asking for and
the kind of experience you won't find
anywhere else so let's start our tour of
Bethesda laying with two VR games coming
out this year you ready
let's take a look
welcome to the UAC
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
turn on your magic
[Music]
and then decide
[Music]
[Music]
finally a full-length open-world game
with near limitless content playable
entirely in VR sure will be exciting to
play fallout 4 in VR plus doom VFR it's
so hot right now
expansive open worlds and endless player
choice are two of the corner stones on
which bethesda was built the Elder
Scrolls online first released in 2014
and has built a massive community since
launch more than 10 million players have
had countless adventures in Tamriel now
you can return to a thrilling
fan-favorite location Mauro in what's up
guys it's a it's Jean this Jamie gonna
be exciting I'm pretty excited right now
here we go oh wait all the collections
my heart's racing right now
[Music]
Lucia narrows into that bear they're not
fair
nice shield are you kidding
that was a meal I can't wait
[Music]
everybody has said this is what we've
been won
Elder Scrolls online made me feel like I
was 14 again
I gotta watch the bear again real quick
it's on a bear
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
speaking of Morrowind did you know that
Bethesda's first PC user mods in 2002
were for the Elder Scrolls 3 morrowind
15 years later but the state continues
to support the mod community last year
bethesda user mods were made available
to Xbox one and PlayStation 4 players
and since then there have been more than
300 million mod on loads for Fallout 4
and Skyrim special edition and we're
just getting started
in 2017 Bethesda is going to shake
things up again
Bethesda Game Studios is known for
creating open living worlds with
seemingly limitless gameplay content but
what if there was another way to
experience even more something all-new
introducing creation club a collection
of new game content for Skyrim and
fallout 4 including new weapons new
armor new outfits and accessories new
crafting and housing features even new
gameplay enhancements using creation
club is easy browse the selection in
game by category and use credits to
download right there your new content
will appear automatically creation club
content is made by Bethesda Game Studios
and outside developers including the
very best community creators these
outside creators work hand-in-hand with
Bethesda Game Studios which means all
content will be fully compatible with
your save games achievements and
official add-ons creation Club is coming
this summer to the PlayStation 4 Xbox
one and PC creation Club the worlds of
fallout 4 and Skyrim just got a little
bit bigger
[Music]
the elderscrolls legends is another way
to explore this amazing universe taking
you beyond the role-playing experience
and offering a unique strategy card game
but we haven't shown all our cards yet
let's see what snacks four legends
[Music]
stories can do surprising things whether
they are true or not and this is one you
should hear
a warrior strength and courage
[Music]
[Music]
even those lost amongst the mountains
can find their way within the stars
the path is written for you to find
the path to warriors destined for
sovngarde
two beasts cursed by an unquenchable
hunger
two scholars of ancient and ferocious
magic
terrors from above
they all await in Skyrim
must simply find the path
[Music]
the elderscrolls has given tens of
millions of fans just like you the
chance to live another life in another
world now for the first time
Skyrim one of our most beloved games is
coming to a Nintendo platform now that's
a switch
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
tomorrow some buildings great sketch
[Music]
well
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bethesda has always believed in
immersive worlds in which players can
tell their own stories be who they want
to be and do what they want to do this
September get ready for another
adventure in the Dishonored universe a
story of revenge and the ultimate
assassination
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now it's good to see you old man you up
for one last job Billy who's the mark
the black eye bastard responsible for
all the chaos we're gonna kill the
outsider
[Music]
in 1996 its software offered gamers a
new exciting way to play and compete
that year marked the true birth of
eSports and it began with the land party
in Dallas Texas fans came together to
play a fast-paced revolutionary new
shooter called quake it offered them a
new way to compete and the best of the
best were finally recognized as
professional gamers this year quake
champions takes eSports to the next
level we weren't born champions were
made
made better
made faster
[Music]
made deadlier with every single match we
don't just play we compete
we achieve
we rise we won't stop until we're the
best
until we are quick champions
coming at you
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
juice it up baby
what's the matter lose something you'll
regret that
try to keep up
Oh who's next
you've done messed up now I'm coming for
you goddamn weirdos
none of you get that alive
you win it all comes down to this every
match every frag every victory more than
20 years in the making
the original eSport returns
announcing the quake World Championships
August 26th at QuakeCon in Dallas Texas
competitors will face off in the
ultimate eSports arena to win their
share of 1 million dollars and the one
thing every champion seeks legacy
play the beta now and get ready for the
quake World Championships physique wait
calm to learn more you might notice some
parts of Bethesda land have been under
construction but now the work is nearly
finished let's take a peek sebastien for
three years since beacon happened you've
been searching for answers you didn't
find what you're looking for because
they didn't want you to mobius knows
you've been following us they've been
watching you for a long time you trained
and trusted me and in return I betrayed
you long before he met he lost her
daughter Lily she's still alive
this is your chance to save her to get
back what you lost Lily needs you you're
gonna need to go back into stem again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today there's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
crazy
where
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow on Friday October 13th the evil
within - will surely be giving us all
nightmares
[Music]
we hope you've enjoyed your time in
Bethesda lab and as we near the end of
our tour we leave you with one more
coming attraction here you go Peggy as
everything your mother ordered and a
ration card and here's a locker each
Necker just for you
Wow gee thanks mr. Wilson
[Music]
I'm gonna get you out get it on we go
good girl
[Music]
[Music]
bad girl
the nutrition is a matter of state
security when the car soldier who ever
lived
[Applause]
welcome back to round three now is where
it gets really exciting on America's
number one game show okay
hands on your buzzers here we go the
honorable use exercise self-control all
the joy and pain Picture Show
second balcony
was the place with meat second seat go
Dutch treat you were sweet
yo and the wake her doom William I
prayed for you to wake up gotten so fat
that says we're having twins uh Franklin
she's been hunting for you she's been
moving heaven and earth and today she
found you you think you're hero William
Joseph Glasgow
foster's did this monsters
hello come on Peter let's go someplace
else
mom no nuts oh btw sure duck you one
strawberry milkshake please oh I hope
you don't have a fire back there to put
out if so I'll come back another time
I'm sure the fire can wait coming done
one strawberry milkshake coming right up
fireman I recognize your face very Aryan
face it is - are you out of station one
there you're coming up Oh
vielen dank mmm
now you show me your identification
papers please
but the fighting spirit back in the
American people
[Music]
shoot us
[Music]
just who the [ __ ] you write boy stay
calm
let me first make it absolutely clear
that I am NOT a Nazi were you saying say
your Nazi I'll [ __ ] this [ __ ]
let me say this again I ain't no goddamn
Nazi huh now you bring superfish back in
and you put him down right now
I will shell this grenade so far up your
ass like I got precious little time for
your [ __ ] we've been trying to make
contact with your group we're organizing
for a revolution in America we
pick up your legs yesterday oh there's
got a sense of humor for the longest
time I've been hearing through the
grapevine about this resistance
leader
Portman you know my mall we said never
trust a man can't handle is whiskey so
you sit right down say tear billion
drink up now listen Tara Billy
I respect your ambition but there's
nothing gonna be done no more the world
has sank into the crapper and all we can
do now is drink this whiskey watch the
vortex suck it all down didn't expect
your belly to be quite so yellow
we stood up against the imperialist war
machine in the United States of America
and the greedy money men of Wall Street
was gonna send the children of the
proletariat off to die on Lance so that
they could be filling their coffers
it worked their sons bleeding on the
beaches I got kids on the way and I'll
be damned if I'm gonna raise them in a
world run by these not yet you take
freedom away from the American people
you're playing with fire
can I attend
see
[Music]
stay stay
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yet
[Applause]
[Music]
I said a couple of months ago that the
thing that machinegames was working on
is [ __ ] bananas so now you know what
I mean by [ __ ] bananas a lady
pregnant with twins stabbing and Nazi
while a guys dropping acid is [ __ ]
bananas
we can't wait to more show to show you
guys more of Wolfenstein 2 and how it
combines a compelling shooter with great
story unforgettable characters and
killer graphics with over-the-top action
so if 2 ends on for our VR titles so you
can play bow ball or and doom before you
can play and start or you can it goes
online moorwen plus we have hands-on for
the new heroes of Skyrim for legends
plus a cool interactive experience for
the evil within two exclusive develop
interviews presentations and a lot more
so we hope you're as excited for what we
have coming in 2017 as we are again a
reminder everything that you saw tonight
be out here via mobile or PC console or
shooter or RPG nor strategy game we
believe Bethesda remain the place to go
for the very best in video games we hope
you've enjoyed this evening showcase
it's your pass in an excitement that
drives our something great something
exciting something fun hey everyone
welcome back to game spots III stage we
just says this press conference thank
you for joining us we're gonna discuss
what we just saw what we missed but all
in all Justin hey wold that was fun yeah
I was excited oh there were screams but
there I felt like I ran the full gamut
of emotions during that presentation in
Wolfenstein alone it's um
I was crying I was a little bit aroused
at time okay just a few it you're here
too
I'm Jess McDonald yeah and off.you here
during our pre-show you know I'm like my
heart of your host and let's just run
through them what we saw what out P
Hines and Bethesda showed us doom VR
Dave as you said you'd kind of heard
circulating rumors making the rounds
what do you think of that I mean again
it's it's it looks fun it looks like
doom it's not the more doom that I
wanted still afraid that it's gonna make
beautiful people motions
it's got that whole teleporting things
you know that's where they're going yeah
it was weird I was talking when we were
watching it like doom so much of doom
from last year was moving forward right
you they the team designed it at it to
always be facilitating momentum and
you're moving forward never backing up
doom VR seems kind of fo VFR what does
that stand for fun budging doing virtual
the [ __ ] reality just be like to be a
it's definitely that's definitely oh oh
I get it
just trying to give me a curse but no it
just seems like kind of contrary what
doom was but um I don't know like we
played Farpoint it now which is like the
last big shooter in VR I guess it might
be like it it's obviously a standalone
thing but yeah it looks more like it's
an experience with pieces they allow you
to shoot yeah so like fiddling with
equipment and armor and so that's right
um yeah but in terms of more VR from
Bethesda they also like we predicted
showed fallout for VR oh okay yeah which
like you know it's not gonna be it's not
gonna be like the standalone earths it's
gonna be the standalone thing but it's
gonna be the entire follow for open
world and Boston post apocalypse in VR
which scene that's a monstrous game I
mean like resi you can play the whole
campaign tour in VR and that's what the
teen hours I mean Whittle yeah 100 hour
game yeah yeah I mean you can't not
possibly play something in VR that said
what an awesome world to be in yeah like
just to be there woman around looking
around oh yeah I saw you gotta be living
somewhere else show I don't know dude I
think I feel like I want to be in a
nicer world well okay well yes Leia like
just go Lucky's tale no we yeah I mean
it just seems we're like I wonder how
much like it looks like they're you know
like they're designing the whole UI the
controls they're revamping everything to
be suitable for VR I'm doc oh yeah that
game is something like Fallout games and
Elder Scrolls games you pour hours and
hours into and imagine in VR for it to
like be comfortable for you stay there
they must have had to take a while
designing this but I mean you can kind
of tell like it doesn't look it looks a
little bit you know parse down from what
we've seen them yeah
and whatnot but it looks pretty good for
VR I'm glad it exists I think like we
needed something like this I would love
to see how the general public responds
to an entire massive single playoff EJ
and we are I mean just see if it works
everyone always says one like if that's
something devs are going to work on then
they're going to want to see that it
actually pans out and that people don't
get sick and you know can keep getting
into virtual reality for long periods of
time to go keep saying they want to make
that yeah well they're there it is I'm
actually more excited for that than I
thought it would be mainly because I
only ever put maybe like 12 hours in the
fallout 4 I fallout 3 a ton new vegas 3
is one of my favorite games but now like
with it I've always been needing excuse
to go back to 4 emits like all these
other games that releases here but now
that's in VR maybe that'll be my you
know the impetus for me to join it again
but I'm pretty excited for that I'm
curious to see how the controls will be
adapted like they keep showing like the
vibe the handset and then the oculus
control or whatever but I wonder if you
could just play it doesn't look like
they're gonna do the resonable 7 thing
the psvr thing where you just play the
controller
I'm wonder if they're implementing that
at all but I would be surprised if they
don't have a whole bunch of different
yeah for how to play I mean it did seem
that the focus was on vibe and not psvr
but I'd surprise if it doesn't come to
both and there's a whole bunch of
options I doubt they'd also drop the
teleportation option for people who get
motion sick as well otherwise they're
losing a whole chunk of that one is who
just cannot like walk around without
getting sick that's a big price of entry
for a game has been out for a while
though right yeah having a vibe and
everything that's big definitely it
seems like a lot of VR experiences right
now are bonuses for people who already
own them but it's also like with PS VR
games that make sense because it kind of
it's a little cheaper it's the most
accessible one to have like with your
PlayStation but it seems like now that
like fallout 4 is aiming for that core
audience I guess it seems like maybe
it'll attract a few more people but that
was the all the VR stuff they showed us
two games that I would not initially
think would be good for VR but it seems
like they're tackling it but uh but as a
creation Club was kind of the like an
anomaly and the whole thing it reminds
me of kind of this what you can do with
the Sims with the microscope that's
exactly what I yeah buy a new furniture
stuff but in this it's a Skyrim and
fallout 4 Bethesda devs and outside
teams they said have made like these new
accessories or outfit
yeah and you can just you get like
currency for that Jassa seem appealing
to you and like the way it's set up
basically buying mods I mean because the
Sims has had this setup for a while but
those who play that you know sims for
sims 3 you can download mods like that
people have created or you can buy the
ones that the company have created I and
I think a lot of other people would
happily take the free ones yeah
I wonder how this is going to go down
you know people don't love being nickel
and dime for little bits and pieces and
because to have an interesting history
with that with the horse armor yeah but
um yeah it doesn't particularly appeal
to me I wonder if there is like certain
ways to end points or if it's just you
buy a pack of them yeah I'm wondering if
like microtransactions are going to
become coming to play heavily with those
yeah they just didn't explain it super
well so interesting to see how that
unravels but if that is what it is and
it's microtransactions that's why they
didn't explain it super well well how
else would you earn credits by playing
good I'm seeing things in a river I'm
worried if they'll go down the route
that you play does we you earn you play
points by getting certain achieved yes
yeah by yeah I have to imagine you but I
mean you that you play does that over
tons of games where this is like two
games yeah I mean they have their own
launcher Nell but it's not the same as
having a platform and again mods exist
guys yeah I know that's what I'm saying
I'm looking at I guarantee people are
gonna just see what is on do their own
sale and then they're just going to make
like a copyright friendly version of it
and put it on a survival mode in there
and survive mode already exists for
Skyrim and fallout 4
I was DLC for Fallout 4 if I'm not
mistaken um I don't know you think
you'll use that too much with probably
not like I love official mods and I tend
to gravitate towards those but I really
unless it's free I don't tend to go into
it you play model could potentially work
I've definitely downloaded stuff on you
played because well I've earned these
credits sure I'll try out some yeah yeah
but otherwise if it is a crude
transaction model that's not gonna make
a lot of people happy and again it's for
games I've been out for a long time yeah
what's the draw yeah I mean like it
while we're still on elder scrolls uh
something we had predicted maybe not we
thought maybe they'll do all the scrolls
legends oh it's on phones tonight but I
know on June 29
next month or late this month it's going
to be coming to iPhone and androids
at least I think they said that's come
because heroes a Skyrim is the new like
audition right is that just new cards
with Skyrim characters I'm surprised
they're not already in it I don't know
it sounds like they're expected because
they added treated each section as it
kind of it's a its own expansion
hearthstone does something similar where
you have each pack is kind of themed
around an idea it sounds like the next
content pack because currently there in
the Dark Brotherhood the next one's
going to go into Skyrim okay makes sense
gotcha and wouldn't you say like the
there in the Dark Brotherhood is that
the cards themselves are the quests that
you mentioned Jess it would be first
okay yeah so one of the problems I found
with legends is that cards are little
say me no matter which of the classes
you choose okay you know if they're
making efforts to kind of change that up
and diversify the classes a bit more in
the cards you get with each of them then
that's interesting to me and might be
interesting to people who are playing
than I am okay um and then yeah while
we're still talking about Skyrim we
talked about it coming to switch right
and they first showed off and kind of
switch with that direct and they showed
Skyrim clearly but then people asked
Bethesda and I think was Piet Hein
specifically he was like it's not
confirmed and that's all he said but of
course now they confirmed it now we know
for sure but it's better than anything I
could have made right so here's my lucky
straight you have a high fantasy
open-world sandbox team and you play
take a walk by Passion Pit I love that
song it is sound a head its usual yeah
it's important evil look at look at this
weird monstrosity of a link hulking
around Skyrim that's it yeah
this I've done this I've had the Master
Sword in Skyrim yeah there's a mod well
that's enough $15 maybe if you're used
to mods then I think you'll be used to
what they're offering here I wonder if
other amiibo are gonna be compatible you
assume they would be yeah I'd like to do
those kinds of things what do you guys
think of the motion controls I was okay
so he's doing this like that looks dope
but then I don't want to be doing that
when I'm just like I love to switch to
the portable I want to be on a plane in
like like if are you gonna be doing that
if it's docked
I'm embarrassed enough to play held on a
plane I don't want to be pretending
anything you put on the plane and you're
just like creme de Chien apologizing the
person next year I'm sorry I'm sorry is
gonna drag it there if I
sitting next to someone a plannig on a
bus and they were doing that I would be
pissed
are you bad respect you'll be able to
play it normally it's not like I don't
yeah I don't I absolutely I love the
idea of Skyrim being at portable right
that's why I love breath of the wild
like taking flights now like eight-hour
flights is nothing because I have a
switch now with Zelda and now I can play
Zelda in Skyrim with this weird-lookin
link I love the idea of putting on my
Pikachu amiibo and getting like a
Pikachu kigurumi that my character will
be like I'll be an electric spell of
something shitty right now yeah probably
or you look like Pikachu yeah I hope
they don't get weird with Tebow support
at the same time you might as well now
it's Nintendo it card already
um but yeah now we know that's on switch
and I'm actually I I said I wouldn't
play the remastered this one came out
last year and I played like 50 hours I
say I'm not gonna play this but again I
will play this probably well I didn't
play the remastered issue because again
I gesture saying if you played up my own
PC there was really no point but now
again like traveling a lot yeah it works
sure it's that link that makes sense
like it's kind of a game that you can
take like few weeks off from and then go
back in and doesn't matter you're not
gonna forget what you were doing because
it doesn't matter um yeah
dishonor to DLC which we forgot to talk
about in the pre-show because it makes
sense right I just released from Arkane
studios what am I on the on the on the
lobby right yeah last week on our live
show we talked about it but uh it shows
and Harvey we talked to Harvey Smith who
was a creative director on this one or
two a few times and he was saying people
are always asking about Meghan Foster
what's her deal because you hear these
little tidbits from her during Tucson or
two she's kind of one of your quest
givers the NPC's that always drives the
boat when you're going into a car knock
are dunwall but she's always people
always saying she's like this badass
character she's kind of like I don't
know it's a weird comparison I've been
making she's kind of the bull the fat
dishonored like you don't Center do too
many cool things but for some reason
Zoe's cult around her and now it
apparently she really is a badass it's
her and dog yeah dog sorry I don't that
yeah that doubt and he of course you
know there's the schism between them but
now they're trying to kill the outsider
which those who don't know what those
who play dishonorable know she he's the
one who gives
Corvo and Emily their supernatural
powers during this I brought the idea to
you Dave the way they're showing doubt
and Megan I wonder if that
same issues between those definitely
looks that way right like that was the
cool thing about dishonor to that
expanded on from the first dishonored
you could be Emily whose powers were
still really cool she had Domino which
Corvo didn't far reach was a little
different blink navigation was little
different but you know it just increased
the replayability the games I have to
imagine they would do the same thing
with Megan Foster endowed I personally
would like to play as Megan foster she's
a badass but it looks like Megan's
powers are gonna be more like mechanical
yes I'm wondering if the scientists like
I remember his name the scientists from
the son of one who soccer loves you yeah
I know that if that yeah who's created
all the time like she's got her arm back
she's got yeah yeah so I'm guessing the
difference is gonna be that she's gonna
have a lot of like mechanical style
powers and doubt will have some of the
old powers that you had from decided one
and then again that call Corvo had
familiar powers from descent one died
will have too many powers of son one you
players Megan sorry yeah there's Megan
if you want to try something different
right um so this would have to take
place after dishonor to the night I
believe so but is in dishonor to she
does not she doesn't have her arm right
um and if I mean if you kill the outside
of it that's why I'm saying doesn't
happen this on three wouldn't happen
like that's a kind of a ballsy move to
yeah it is interesting
kill the things that I introduced a new
outsider so yeah there's multiple
outsider wasting you baddies he does
hint at this he does hit the idea in
dishonor to of there being others right
yeah isn't he at some point maybe
they'll just that's the impression I
always got from the world anyway but it
seems like this is the exact time to do
it right there was what were the DLC for
the first game which is a rig more knife
of dunwall cops after we're seven months
after launch now so make sense yeah well
and you know like prey just released so
it seemed like a time for to kind of
fill the gaps
maybe I'm sure they'll be prey DLC maybe
six months from now while they're like
maybe announcing a new dishonored or
something else they might tackle but
yeah we will actually have Harvey Smith
on our live show Wednesday to talk about
that more which I'm pretty excited about
but I'm really excited to go back into
data dishonor to because like most of
arcane stuff like the immersive sim
games they have a lot of replayability
whether you want to choose korva or
Emily and you know presumably maybe you
can do Megan
and and I've been supporting Dishonored
- a lot they had that they did that game
where you could have a mix mash of of
powers but yeah new characters so I
wonder if they'll do something similar
and be able to yeah you could have four
put people's worth of powers and play
exactly the way you want yeah I like the
idea that like with the previous
dishonored like with a lot of Bethesda
games that this isn't DLC that we knew
about that was going to come out right
at at a time location like it felt like
yeah is it time to breathe we have to
create this and to make a really good
separate experience yeah yeah it's not
like a you know pre-order to someone
dozen or two you'll have what's called
death of the outsider end of the
outsider that's it does the outsider
it's coming out September fifteenth side
note everything but says the show
tonight is coming out this year so crazy
oh yeah you're like it's weird because
we kind of we're gonna talk about evil
than to and Wolfenstein two both of
which we expected because of leaks or
job postings you know like it was weird
like during I was waiting for a huge
surprise and I didn't get it but I think
like it was still a strong showing in
terms of the games and it's also like
we're gonna play all these or the next
six months it was pretty exciting
because again that's what they did with
fallout 4 they're like oh it's also
coming out in like four months
also here's fallout shelter seem to be
but Bethesda is kind of like mo now but
I do want to talk about quake champions
because we knew we were going to see
that but we didn't really see anything
new like I said it was just easier like
Neth it was kind of shot or support for
eSports the original eSport coming back
not unions
you're not champions you're you're
skilled warriors yeah no it's I wanted I
just rather would have seen something
new but I mean I guess they kind of like
got their message across with quake
champions what is right and I mean the
new thing is able eSports and BJ basket
yeah yes yeah I mean like Dave you see
anything that made you more excited for
the game are you still pretty much no
I'm not good enough a quake to win a
million dollars yeah so no see it made
me think I'm not good enough at quake to
play quake champion yeah um yeah BJ bat
blaskowitz of course being kind of the
dual wielding thing wasn't something I
told much within the I think about now
the dual wielding thing is BJ blaskowitz
is unique about right oh that makes
sense yeah um that okay yeah but like
the games in beta now you know play it
if you want to close beta or opa mater
you closed a you you can go to like that
just dishing out keys anyway though so
you can go to the website and get key
you can go play quake champions if you
want to before we get into
of ensign to the new Colossus as we had
talked about was probably called the
evil within to again that job hosting
for psycho break2 came up in like recent
weeks or months as well but of course
like tango gameworks under Shinji Mikami
and publisher Bethesda has been saying
they wanted to make this a franchise so
my prediction was that maybe they'll
ditch Sebastian Castellanos for a little
bit and go after someone else just to
create this cast this crazy but now he's
coming back and he's going for his
daughter still clearly the psychological
trauma conceit of this the horror in
this game just as this game kind of get
you excited from we saw tonight I mean I
love psychological horror I think it's
super interesting and I just love what
Japan does with their horror games I
think that better at it than anybody
else um I think it's still gorgeous it's
a great looking game I think it's gonna
be like super scary um yeah the little
girl going up in flames in the forest
that was that happened yeah it looks
like a mannequin like a Monday for me uh
yeah it looks like it's gonna throw you
for a loop it looks like they're
probably upping the ante even more on
this psychological horror front what was
the what was the character that was in
your like hub that give you your
upgrades or you talked to her she's at
the desk in between I forget her name
but she made a return and these yeah I
think she's the one talking to you
actually yeah she might be milk though I
don't know this is like a dusting creepy
scary yeah imagine like being in a bath
full of milk you how seemed strength you
seem excited a little bit oh yeah this
is about earlier uh ya know this part
this kind of gets brutal but of course
the first game kind of got taxing but
I'm really hoping that they figured out
how to not end a game terribly like to
find out the first one because I like I
said I love the first ten chapters it
was Mikami doing some of his best work
at moments but there were so many things
bringing the rest of it down and the
team at tango clearly knows how to make
a good survival horror game it's kind of
underground this Renaissance recently
you know like again after the
cancellation of silent Hills but then
resin will seven kind of revived and I
think maybe we're riding a wave of this
kind of stuff now I'm hoping and evil
within to comes out Friday October 13th
what about over in VR experience with
this what if they did a view or don't
know be interesting right you think you
think VR be better suited for
first-person but then something like
edge of nowhere comes out or Crone
Cronos both of which were third person
who worked really well edge of nowhere
you're kind of behind the character and
shining the light with you where you
look Chronos who actually just this it
was a third-person action game but it'd
be nice for them to do via it's
something that hasn't been out for a
damn long time yeah Louis to support
yell support yeah
lovey I mean like seems like they're
making a big push for it they started
the whole show off BR but I guess it
would kind of make sense to go into this
I mean like resonable 7 worked really
well with VR I think and it wasn't like
too taxing on me I don't really get
motion sick most the time but I've heard
from people to do that resonable said
him did it well so I wonder if they did
they would choose to pursue it here
seems like I don't know if that's
something from Bethesda going down to
like hid and you know the internal
studio doing fallout 4 I wonder if they
would talk to tango at some point about
doing that be interesting to see maybe
and another game that we expected but
one that got a lot of time at the end of
the show
Wolfenstein - the new Colossus is the
thing BJ blaskowitz coming back and Dave
as you and a bunch people predicted it's
in America Nazi occupied America Anya
from New Order is pregnant with twins
now of course but she's also stabbing
the [ __ ] out of somebody which is kind
of well yeah but would you think of this
trailer day based on your time with new
order it gave me a lot of things to
think about so like when BJ wakes up it
looks like he's lost the the use of his
legs and then later you see him in
that's the Power Suit it's got it's it's
got strange net it's like an old Hebrew
name I think it's the power suit that
you find in the previous game it looks
like he's using that to walk and then
later on the game you see him punching
through walls so it looks like he's
gained a lot of strength and a lot of
powers from from wearing a suit all the
time yeah my Hebrew is kind of shaky but
uh the dot yehud that one yeah it looks
cool it looks like almost like a pyramid
head I'm guessing that's it he's growing
at the entire game yeah it looks like
there are some returning characters the
big guy max Hass yeah
it looks like he's back and one thing
you pointed out was that the dual
wielding isn't stuck to the same weapon
right you can have a totally different
weapon in each hand score which I love
the aesthetic
I'm hugely sold on this creepy like
overly friendly Nazi officer shtick who
always works always makes you feel super
unsettled yeah I'm a fan of that I'm
guessing he gets his head caved into the
counter next to him and you always feel
good about that yeah yeah that's the
thing about Wolfenstein you can play a
guilt free because you can sit um yeah
and then I mean the areas are going I
believed in yes you're like it's going
for like a fall out kind of like 50 60 s
Americano vibe - like I got music with
the like the died like diners the
overall like vibe of it the educated in
big afros I love the game show they
showed that the name of the show with
German dot that thought or else
everybody's super happy
uh yeah I'm really looking forward to so
of course it's like a new resistance
group that you're helping it's just like
inspiring hoping them and having them
fight back against Nazi occupiers always
good yeah I'm dropping acid drop Issei
yeah this damn cute little character who
shows up at the end I hope he's a part
of the game as well um Frau Ango from
the first game she's one of you have
that pretty tense conversation with on
the train toward the beginning yes Sonic
she died really horribly he in the
previous game what happened to her he
was like it was it was when you were
sent to the prison camp and we escaped
and she gets like just mangled by a
sheen really
so the Perry not make it oh yeah maybe
the supernatural stuff from old blood
unless I'm completely misremembering by
I'm 99% sure that she got horrible in
the vo I think was Anya telling BJ that
angle was hunting him right didn't she
say like prowling I've been hunting you
it wouldn't surprise me because she
little bit deeper on them yeah I mean
I'd be pissed at him but but then it was
weird we were talking about New Orleans
potentially being in like an obsidian
yeah somehow though you go down New
Orleans yes and then eating alligators
uh what do you think of that like it's
not just gonna be you think it's gonna
be like an American like hopping across
the country kind of thing like if you're
trying to get the whole country right
yeah that would be cool maybe we'd have
to go to other places
yeah and maybe if they want to keep a
new Colossus connection that maybe New
York would be the end point yeah they're
cool but it would be good I mean
exploring more of America means you get
more in
more scenery more like gameplay elements
we did see some like you mentioned that
it felt a big 5x5 with this this scene
with the via the religious aspect and
there were KKK members being arrested
occupation of America but like also like
extreme right people we're writing like
I mean like obviously like in this case
like radical people and in Far Cry 5
radical as well but it's weird that like
kind of coincidence that both are
bringing it to American soil with these
like clearly usually political yeah and
I'm storylines yeah oh yeah I mean if
you're members there can I'm is you're
not gonna feel guilty about it right
right and then like BJ gets on his uh
like the mechanical dog I love how it
started first of all happened I talked
about at the live-action Andy Griffith
Show girls calling a weasel Hurley and a
dog to come help the police officers but
then he started breeding fire on
everything it felt like they actually
took old footage of some like obscure
movie yeah and there's first that like
I'm curious how they did yeah and and as
much as I'd love new order it was kind
of after a while is a lot of this
industrial European medieval look I
would love it if they actually did go
across America see this yeah Islands
right here I see the alligator coming up
soon yeah everything they did with new
order they they gave it so much
character by doing German versions of
songs that you'd expect in that time so
now looks like they're doing German
versions of the television you find at
that time it really like ground it and
give it a sense of alternate timeline
yeah and you Dave you said you mentioned
in your watching gameplay that it looks
like you're using the suit itself in
like your abilities maybe I better
because you have the three perk trees in
the first game which like based on
challenges you complete you unlock new
ones I wonder if that's going to affect
the suits can affect those about yeah
that's like gonna be the RPG ish part of
it I think so I mean in the previous
game it was it was given to the leader
resistance the old lady because she lost
the use of her legs so I'm assuming BJ
gets that and we see him punch through
walls it wouldn't surprise me if you get
like a strength perk that does that and
agility perk that lets you jump up super
high and maybe something else to
compliment that maybe the whole
different dual wielding thing becomes a
perk
yeah so it wouldn't surprise me if that
power suit is was the core mechanic that
gave a lot of the BJ to power yeah
that man no no why I just wanted to talk
about how awful Wolfenstein to October
27th as with the rest of the Tesla's
press conference will be out this year
that's two weeks after the evil then to
September 15th its honor to DLC Elder
Scrolls legends here the Skyrim is
coming June 29th a lot of stuff coming
out this whole year you're still
laughing aren't you all right all in all
Dave would you think at a conference um
I'm super excited super stoked for
Wolfenstein everything else kind of Luke
wants me to be honest
Justin you're crying did say it made you
cry you think of the conference good
showing uh that was fun though it's
especially because all this is coming in
2017 like that's such such an exciting
thing to say like it lets you know
Bethesda has stuff that they're hiding
stuff that we're gonna learn that's
gonna leak out eventually
yeah but 2017 is gonna be so crazy yeah
um that is I wonder what they would have
talked about if they went past like into
2018 but just raw what do you think of
like this year's um I think there are
definitely bright spots I'm excited for
evil within Wolfenstein looks great they
make beautiful games um kind of wish I
spent a little less time on things we
already knew about like morrowind but
you know I mean even the Lincoln switch
like that's a fun moment for everyone
I'll take it
yeah if you've been paying attention to
like news and leaks lately over the past
week or a couple weeks and might not
have been too many surprises for you at
the press conference tonight for
Bethesda but all in all yeah
everything's coming out this year two
new sequels
fallout for VR doom VR Elder Scrolls
legends coming to phones later this
month Skyrim on switch finally confirmed
even though somehow wasn't before but
yeah that is the Bethesda press
conference we are going to be live on
GameSpot XIII stage tomorrow for Ubisoft
and Sony later in the day gonna do a pre
and post-show for those and stream those
from YouTube to which GameSpot as well
we also like I said have dishonored DLC
coming to the lobby our live show
Wednesday morning on our downstairs
stage we're gonna have Harvey Smith on
to talk about that and then also just
throughout the week we're going to have
people coming on to either do interviews
or just play games in general so of
course stay tuned to get more news from
III from GameSpot and we will see you
tomorrow have a good night
yep